MANO MARKS:: Hi.
Welcome to the Google Geo
Developers series.
I'm Mano Marks.
I'm a developer advocate on
Google's Geo Developer
Relations team.
I'd like to introduce you today
to John Coryat, who is
going to be giving you a talk on
simulating map markers with
tile layers.
John did one of our most widely
viewed talks in the Geo
Developers series in 2007 on
creating custom map types, and
that still has a lot
of techniques
that are valid today.
So I encourage you view
that, as well.
So take it away, John.
JOHN CORYAT: Simulating markers
with a tile layer.
This discussion is aimed at
those who understand advanced
mapping techniques and have a
good knowledge of server-side
languages and the Google
Maps v3 JavaScript API.
My name is John Coryat.
I'm with USNaviguide LLC I've
been working with Google Maps
API since 2005, and I've created
dozens of web pages
that use custom tile layers.
We suggest that you view the
prerequisite to this
discussion called Producing
Custom Maps
with Google Maps API.
You can find it on Google by
searching for Coryat, Google,
and custom maps.
It's a YouTube video.
It focuses on the basics of the
tile system, tile math,
and covers creating tiles
from large images.
Also, why you would use a tile
layer, which is sort of an
important topic.
We suggest that you go through
the examples on that
discussion, and view
that before
proceeding with this one.
Everyone is familiar
with the results of
a Google Map search.
Here we have a search for coffee
shops that has a number
of lettered markers.
Those are JavaScript objects.
And also there's a secondary
result, which are the little
red dots that are scattered
about the map.
Those are also active simulated
markers that, when
clicked on, will bring
up a result.
What you may not know is that
those markers are actually a
tile layer, and Google has
used this technology to
display more results
than they could if
they just used markers.
Since it limits the number of
JavaScript objects, it allows
them to depict hundreds more
results than they could if
they just used the lettered
markers, which should probably
be kept somewhere between
50 and 200 as a
maximum results set.
You could leverage this
technology for your own maps.
If you have a problem of trying
to display more than a
couple hundred points, this is
an excellent way to do that.
The advantages are that it's
very fast, it's an efficient
use of memory, and it doesn't
require JavaScript objects for
each marker that you display.
Instead, it uses the tiles,
which are just images.
So you can put as many little
points on those images as you
want, and it doesn't impact the
performance of the web page.
Another thing that's good about
to using this method is
that it's more secure than
using JavaScript objects.
When you use straight markers,
what you have to do is you
have to pass all the data--
the coordinates, the HTML,
everything that you need to
display the markers has to be
passed, either as XML stream,
JSON, or embedded directly
in your web page.
This would allow an unscrupulous
developer to
harvest your data and use
it for their own use.
By using a tile layer, you're
obfuscating your data somewhat
in that you're just passing a
tile with marker images on it.
That still could be taken
apart by a fairly clever
programmer, but you're making
it a lot more difficult for
them to do it.
Plus, then all they have
is the coordinate.
They don't have any of the
HTML that goes behind it.
They have to go and harvest that
data from your server as
a separate step.
I think you making it more
difficult for them, the odds
are they'll leave your data
alone if you have
this type of method.
It does have a disadvantage in
that it requires additional
bandwidth to transmit tiles, and
it requires a round-trip
to the server when you click
on a marker in order to
retrieve the data.
Here's an example page that
we're going to use for this
demonstration.
It's the volcanoes of the world
from the Smithsonian
volcano project.
There are approximately 1,300
points included in this map.
It works from zoom level 3 to
10, which is approximately
4,000 tiles.
As you can see, it looks
like they are markers.
And they, in fact, are just
images on the tile layer.
Now let's go to the demo.
Start the recording.
OK, here we have the
volcano web page.
And as you can see, it looks
like there are lots
of markers on there.
And they're all kind of
clustered together.
You can go around the
world with it.
You can see it's quite snappy.
It has no delay, even
though they're
showing so many markers.
Of course, they're
not real markers.
They're points embedded
in a tile.
And as we zoom in, they
become separated,
as you would expect.
You can see there are a lot
of volcanoes in Japan.
And you can click on them.
And that brings up a result.
And as we zoom in further--
this is approximately zoom
level seven, I believe.
I changed the icon.
You can do all kinds of things
on the server when you have
the control of processing
it on the server side.
For instance, you could use a
clustering algorithm to--
instead of showing them all in
a big line, you could have a
square, and put like 10, or 30,
or something like that in
it to depict those markers.
That's a very common way of
doing it, but you could have
all that power on the server.
Whereas, if you're delivering
markers to your web page, you
have to handle all that
on the client.
And that becomes a very
slow, draggy process.
Here again, we'll click
on that one.
And there's another one brought
up as an info window.
Now, one thing that's important
as a concept is the
concept of tolerance.
Now, if I click out here in the
middle of the ocean where
there are no volcanoes, I get a
message saying that there's
no volcano within range.
If I click relatively close,
it still gives me that.
I have to click virtually on top
of the marker in order to
bring up the info window.
This is a concept
of tolerance.
I use between 0 and 15 pixels
is considered a valid click.
So that's something we'll talk
about later, but I just wanted
to demonstrate tolerance.
All right.
So that's the demonstration.
We'll go back to the slides.
That concludes the demo.
We include a useful Perl
module with this
demonstration, or with
this discussion.
This is called
USNaviguide_Google_Tiles.pm.
It does all the tile
math for you.
It has methods for calculating
all sorts of things that you
might want to know about your
points or whatever, and it has
to do with the tiles.
For instance, you can calculate
all the tiles for a
bounding box, or you can
calculate all the features for
a single tile.
Or you can calculate a tile name
for a pixel location, or
convert a coordinate to a
pixel or a pixel to a
coordinate.
Or find the name of a tile from
a pixel coordinate, or a
pixel location, and zoom.
These are very important things
that you'll need if
you're going to do any of
this tile-based work.
Two things that were used in
this particular discussion are
converting a coordinate--
a latitude and longitude
coordinate--
to a pixel location, and also
taking a coordinate and
finding the name of the tile
that belongs with that.
This is discussed in the
previous prerequisite.
So if you have any questions
about tile math or the
coordinates--
how the coordinate system works
for the tile system--
I suggest you review that
prerequisite, as it goes over
all these things in
great detail.
When you're simulating markers
on a tile layer, it takes a
couple of steps to do this.
First thing you do is you
calculate the tiles that are
required, along with the
positions for the icon images
on those tiles.
And the second step is
to draw those tiles.
And it does sound simple.
It is fairly simple.
It requires two tables
and a database.
We used PostgreSQL for this
demonstration, which has some
really great features, some
spatial features like finding
points closest to
a coordinate.
Things like that are very
useful in this type of
discussion.
The two tables we use, one is
the data table which contains
the name, the HTML for the
info window, and the
coordinate of the volcano.
And then we create a temporary
table that contains the zoom
number, the x and y tile
numbers, and the pixel
location for the top left corner
of the icon image.
Now, the top left corner is
important, because that's the
only thing you need to know
about placing an icon image on
a tile image.
You need to know the
top left corner.
That's your anchor point
when merging images.
We use the GD library.
It's a really good graphics
library for
creating these images.
I'm sure that if you're not
able to use GD, there's
another one called
ImageMagick.
That's another great
library, and there
must be one for .net.
I don't know the name of it,
but I'm sure there's a good
one for that, as well.
Now when you're calculating the
tiles required, you have
this little issue that pops up,
and that's that icons can
overlap tiles.
A coordinate itself, or point,
like the point of a volcano,
will only be on one tile.
But when you expand it out to an
icon, which in this case is
a 24 by 24 pixel image,
it can easily overlap
onto separate tiles.
Here you see icons are
overlapping onto the adjacent
tile, which is something
you have to handle.
Here's a worst case
scenario where you
have an anchor point--
the point itself is located in
the upper left hand corner of
tile number four, within
just a couple of
pixels of the tile boundary.
In this case, we're using the
center of the tile as the
anchor point.
So if the coordinate is within
12 pixels, or half the icon
size, of the boundary of the
tile, then that tile is going
to overlap onto the next tile.
We have to be able to handle
this in order to show the tile
layers correctly.
Now, there are two ways that
I've come up with to do this.
One is called the fudging
method, where you force a
coordinate or an icon
to be on one tile.
And the other is the exact
method, where you handle this
problem so that it's
shown correctly.
Now with the fudging method,
what you do is you simply
slide the anchor point of the
icon whatever number pixels
you have as overlap so that
the icon fits on one tile.
This could be very useful for
a number of conditions.
Here we show the fudging method,
where we've moved
these overlapping tiles.
You see on the before fudge,
you see some of the icons
overlapping.
And after the fudge, the icons
reside on the tile.
This works well for large
features, such as cities,
parks, states, zip codes, post
codes, things like that that
the icon could reside anywhere
inside that aerial feature and
still be accurate.
Where it starts to fall apart is
if you're trying to depict
point features, like buildings,
or parks, or cars
on roads, things like that--
transit stations.
Anywhere where the icon, even
moving it a few pixels is
going to affect the accuracy
of the map, fudging isn't
really a good choice.
Another place where fudging
doesn't work really well is if
you have a very large
number of icons.
If you have a large number of
icons, what happens when you
fudge them is you create
artifacts on your tiles where
the boundaries of the tiles will
be the only place that
will be devoid of icons.
And it's very obvious
to the eye once you
run into that situation.
Using the exact method, what
you do is you calculate the
tiles that are required for
each corner of the icon.
And if they all are the
same, then the icon
resides on one tile.
If they're not, then it's
overlapping somewhere.
And what you do is you take the
tiles that are for each
corner, and then you calculate
the position of the upper
left-hand corner of the icon
for each of those tiles.
And you add that into your
temporary table that we've
created earlier.
Now, what this can cause is, for
instance, in tile number
four, the upper left hand corner
for the icon is off the
tile completely.
It's up into tile number one.
So for tile number four, that
will give you relatively
negative coordinates
for that tile.
And so when you go to draw that
tile, you'll be trying to
draw that icon starting in
a negative coordinate.
Now, with GD this is handled
beautifully.
It just will slide your icon
image out into nowhere, into
nothingness, and only paint onto
your tile the part of the
icon image that should
be there.
So check your documentation with
whatever you're going to
be using, and make sure that a
negative coordinate will not
cause some sort of issue.
If it does, you'll have to
handle it differently.
But negative coordinates
work well with GD.
And the only time in this
particular worst case scenario
that the tile coordinates will
be positive is in tile number
one where the upper left
hand corner resides
actually on the tile.
In two, three, and four, there
will be at least one negative
coordinate.
Now once you've cycled through
all your points and calculated
the upper left-hand corners for
all the tiles that you're
going to need, and you select
a distinct list of the tiles
that are required.
That's Select Distinct based
on the x and y tile names.
And that gives you your
list of tiles
that you have to produce.
Then you cycle through those,
one at a time, and you gather
all the points for that tile
that you are working on, and
cycle through the records and
your temporary table, and draw
onto that tile the icons.
And then you output the tile,
and you go through until
you've completed
the whole set.
What you're creating is what's
called a sparse tile-set.
In other words, there
will only be tiles
for ones with data.
You won't be creating
tiles that have no
data, no blank tiles.
Now what this ends up doing is,
in this case, we create
4,000 tiles that have icon
images on them for the entire
world, zooms 3 to 10.
Now, if we were to create blank
tiles, in addition to
tiles with data, we'd be
creating 1.4 million tiles.
But by only producing tiles
that have data, we create
4,000 tiles, which is
significantly less.
That saves both in
time to process.
It saves on space
on the server.
It also allows the server to
retrieve the tiles a lot
faster, because it doesn't have
to go through so many.
We recommend also that you keep
your tiles in a separate
directory for each zoom level.
That facilitates recreating a
particular zoom level, and it
also allows the server to pick
them up a lot faster.
Once you've created your tiles,
then the next thing is
to handle the simulated
marker clicks.
Now, the way this works is you
create a listener in your
JavaScript, in your map,
so that you're
listening for clicks.
When you get a click, what you
do is you send the click
coordinate and the zoom to your
server for processing.
The server click handler selects
the closest point out
of the database to the click,
and then checks to make sure
that it's within tolerance.
And the way you do that is
with a simple distance
formula, which is x1 minus x2
squared plus y1 minus y2
squared equals the number of
pixels distance from the point
that was clicked on to the point
that was selected out of
the database.
If that is within
the tolerance--
and my usual number is somewhere
between 10 and 20.
Mobile-type applications, I
suggest go a little bit
higher, perhaps 20 pixels,
because it's going to be
selected by a finger.
But for regular desktop
applications, 10 pixels is
usually enough--
then you generate the XML that's
required by the client
to produce an info window.
Send that back, and then the
client displays the results.
It's fairly simple, and it
doesn't require a lot of code.
Now, one thing that you're going
to get is you're going
to have a problem
with 404 errors
that you have to handle.
You don't have to handle it, but
it's probably a good idea
to handle them with
the tile server.
If you don't intercept the
request for a tile with a tile
server, what ends up happening
is your error logs get loaded
with a lot of messages,
404 messages.
If, on the other hand, you
handle your 404 errors or your
tile requests with a tile
server, what you can do is
check to see if the
tile exists.
If the tile exists, you
send it to the client.
If it doesn't exist, you
send a blank image
instead of a 404 error.
This allows the server
to operate faster.
It doesn't create a whole lot
of crap error messages in
error logs.
And you also can do some things
like, for instance, you
can hide your tile directory
below the web viewable part in
your server for security.
You can also control access to
your tiles by embedding a
security code in your web page
that's passed to the request.
And if the security code doesn't
match or is incorrect,
you either deliver
an error message,
nothing, or a blank tile.
And this will help keep
unscrupulous web developers
from taking your hard-earned
work and putting it
in their own pages.
Well, that's the end
of this discussion.
We have some resources that
go along with this.
The program to create the
tiles is included.
The v3 web page is included.
The volcano.pl is the
click handler.
We include that as well.
The tile server that we just
discussed, the data itself,
which you can download directly
from the Smithsonian
volcano project.
But we have it in a Postgres
dump format, which will make
it easier if you're using
Postgres, the Perl module for
doing the tile math.
We have the slides that
were used in this
presentation as a PDF.
We also have an article that
gives a synopsis of this
discussion.
All above materials are
available under the Apache
license, so use them
as you see fit.
And the URL for that is
www.usnaviguide.com/ws-2010-08.
Thank you very much.